Hello?
Hi Amanda, what have you been doing?
I've been working all day.
What makes you so busy?
My sister got married last year.
She gave birth to a boy two days ago.
Congratulations!
Thank you.
Now, I have three nieces and two nephews.
I'm so happy.
Wow, you have a lot of nieces and nephews.
Yes.
We are a large family.
That's great!
How many brothers and sisters do you have?
I have one sister and two brothers.
Did they all get married?
Yes, that's why I have many nieces and nephews.
Okay, that makes sense.
My big brother has two daughters and a son.
But my sister-in-law wants to have one more baby.
Wow.
She wants to have a big family, too.
Yes.
My sister-in-law was the only child.
She said she always felt lonely when she was young.
That's why she wants to have many children.
I think so.
Actually, I also want to have more nieces and nephews.